and Russia's military continues to claim
it's stopped across border attack from
Kiev Moscow says forces kill more than
70 Ukrainian saboteurs when they
attempted to cross into the Belgrade
region let's talk about it in more
detail with Major General Rupert Jones
but former senior British army officer
it's good to see you thanks for joining
us on the program what do you think has
gone on there then
well I'm gonna end up with a degree of
confusion claims and counter claims but
it appears that too Russian uh
pro-ukrainian pots and groups have
conducted some kind of incursion into
into the area of Belgrade talk of four
Villages having been taken the Russians
claiming now to have defeated that that
attack and that is probably the case but
but it'll take time time to verify it so
that appears to be what's happened of
course what's interesting is is what it
what it all means and I suppose there's
probably three bits to that I mean from
a Russian perspective it points to an
internal security problem it's it's
humiliating with them there's an attack
onto their own soil from a western point
of view it will cause some concern to
what degree was Ukraine supportive of
that incursion uh when we're giving
weapons we're concerned about those
weapons being used into Russia so
there'll be some diplomatic concerns I
guess from an Ukrainian point of view
it's uh appealing because it does two
things firstly it draws attention away
from what is or isn't happening in in
back mood it takes the eyes away have
Russia taken uh back mood once and for
all but also
we assume we continue to assume the
ukrainians are getting ready for their
big offensive and that being the case
they'll want to draw the Russians eye
away from where that attack might come
what does it mean for Putin Putin when
he took his country into the war had
said that he was doing that as a matter
of self-defense because they were
worried about what Ukraine was going to
do it would appear that he can't keep
his people safe
absolutely so I mean I think we've
recognized all along that there is a a
uh a minority how big is that Minority
maybe even a majority who don't support
the war it's very hard to get really
accurate accurate figures on that but
this is a really clear example of those
who don't support the war taking action
into into their own hands a very brave
move
talk to me about what in your opinion
has happened in back mode I mean it's
been an absolute meat grinder there for
more than a year uh what would a victory
look like and to whom well indeed so so
brigosian who who heads Up the Volume
group has said over the last couple of
days that bakamut has finally been taken
and indeed that he is going to hand over
Bak moot to the Russian army take his
own forces back out of the line to
reconstitute for two months that in
itself is telling because it in military
parlance it tells you his Force has
culminated they've got no more fight in
them they've got to come out of the line
the ukrainians are are denying that back
moot has completely Fallen
discuss what does it actually mean for
back moot to have been taken or not to
be taken it looks as though Ukraine
still hold a small uh area in the west
of the town but critically it also
appears that they're still advancing
around the sides of back booth at back
moot attacking the Russians from the
North and the South and indeed attacking
their supply loans behind but I think
the very fact we're having this
conversation points to points to what
we've always said the back moot as a
town is not that significant and so you
know you don't get this big moment where
the Russians have taken it or the
ukrainians have taken it
um and so what it feels a fairly Hollow
win if indeed it turns into a win but
why waste so many lives
um with symbolism well indeed well for
the Russians I think it's it it's always
about symbolism Putin the Russian
culture is very much about symbolism and
of course they've had a pretty awful War
so far they haven't had any victories
and we've just been talking about the
Russian people they need they need some
victory they need some some good news
and back mood became symbolic from that
point of view from a Ukrainian point of
view
you don't want to give the Russians that
win but critically it has been an
opportunity to really really wear down
the Russian military huge amounts of
Russian casualties there well the same
on both sides indeed so but but in by
way of ratio many many more for the
Russians I mean the Americans have have
given a figure a month or so ago over a
hundred thousand Russian casualties in
in back mode
um the ukrainians I think the figure is
about a factor of one to six ratio of
coaches between the ukrainians and the
Russians that is still a very
significant loss for the ukrainians but
I think they've made a strategic
judgment that that is in their interest
to really grind down the Russians in
Baku while they prepare for an offensive
when they're ready for it and where do
you think we are on this spring
offensive that we keep hearing so much
about
um it's we're expecting it in March then
April then may we're almost in June I
suppose the Russians are potentially
thinking it's not coming yeah I mean I
think they'll be wrong to think that I
suspect probably they know it is coming
they're very very much you know ready
for it exactly when it comes is is hard
to tell and of course Ukraine will want
to keep us and indeed most importantly
the Russians guessing about that they
won't go until they're they're
absolutely ready and as ready as they
can be and they'll be taking advice from
from the West about that about when
they've got the most amount of Western
Equipment capability ready to take in
take into the fight and when it comes I
don't think we should expect it to be a
you know a big all-in moment because
what an offensive this typically looks
like is they'll probably attack in
different directions and try and get the
Russians guessing moving their reserves
hither and then thither and so they can
then break through these this strong
crust of Russian defenses but this war
is set to continue for some time yeah I
mean I'm never one person so putting
time frames on it but yes you know look
at it you know this year it's been
stable hasn't it brutal huge casualties
but but it hasn't been a lot of movement
in the front line for you know five
months or so now so even if the
ukrainians break through the front line
gain some real momentum into their into
their counter-offensive
you know the war is the war is not in uh
you know the end is not imminent not
least because we know although um
president zelenski has been uh
successful in trying to get hold of some
f-16s
that's a long time process it is and you
know we've we've discussed before you
know why did the West take so long to
make that that decision it was a little
bit like the tanks we're not giving
tanks we're not giving tanks we're
giving tanks we've had the same with
f-16s I think it's fantastic that the
decision has now now been taken there's
a little training Coalition developing
uh some people are saying that there
could be f-16s available in Ukraine by
the Autumn I think it'll take time for
that to really clarify
um my my air pair colleagues you know
the purest amongst them would would say
it takes a very long time to train a
pilot to develop a you know an air power
capability what the ukrainians have
demonstrated is that they're the Arts of
it the artists of innovation and so
they'll need the limited amount of
training and they'll get the aircraft
into the fight with
room holiday we've missed you thanks for
joining us an absolute pleasure thanks a
lot